another qga ish why a different move
order in a game between Magnus and
Prague which as is the norm started once
again by the IC 454 Knights line Magnus
once again goes E3
um
this is the line where he lost another
back after another bit played E5 right
that game went E5 which will do D5 cd5
95 castles which would be 75 and white
ended up over pressing and eventually
losing but uh plug goes for much more uh
safe option goes E3 6045
and after A3
uh I had this conversation with Jan when
we were doing sidges and uh Jan informed
me that uh it's very much the current
understanding here
to go DC4 and then A6 because the other
options uh aren't as clear and don't
seem to be equalizing as comfortably
these days whereas this
looks like a very decent qga where white
committed to both Knight C3 and A3 and
in particular in ic3 is not always the
move you want to make this early in in
qga positions uh but Marcus is playing
very quickly so I guess he uh had a
pretty decent idea of how Prague will
react to various things because Bishop
D3 that's right the main line is just
the castle and
yeah I haven't seen Bishop D3 before
exactly here yeah Bishop D3 I guess you
are kind of threatening to play what
uh is very close to Pure Foreman I think
the the it's called the form the ideas
of let's say if you play Bishop B7 which
is not a very important move we've
prevented the queen trade and then we
want to push for these types of ideas uh
Proctor cd484 and interestingly just
goes G6 here uh uh also showing another
side to this black isn't committed to
developing the bishop normally to E7 and
with an isolating on G4 it obviously
makes a ton of sense to try to get it to
G7 where uh it will help generating
pressure against the pawn on D4 one is
going to Bishop G5 Bishop G7 and just
blitzes out which B4 I'm surprised the
blessing I I'm not familiar with this uh
neither a branch of the line maybe there
have been games recently uh or kind of
core games 97 has been played Among Us
just blitzes out h2h4
some deep preparation clearly uh
provokes H6 because I guess this is kind
of uncomfortable now that Knight F6 is a
move and also you really cannot Castle
into H5 there's no way you can afford to
just ignore this yeah so Prague
understandably plays a six month
mistakes ghost 22. okay and uh so he's
dark black from castling but if black
plays Bishop G7 this Magnus going long
actually liking a fake yeah although G4
might come and trap your Bishop G4 G5 or
let's say Bishop c294 is worrying me a
little bit Yeah it feels like black
should be completely fine I don't really
see too many plans for white other than
at some point D5 or maybe G4 G5 you
spent 15 minutes yeah he's he spent uh
20 minutes on 97 which is quite a lot of
time but we like the move so we don't
really mind that all that much h4h6 was
played quickly of course no thinking
here and then 95 took him an additional
15 minutes okay but Magnus is also
thinking now Magnus uh spend quite a bit
of time on H5 uh G5 a very natural reply
by Prague I don't hate his position to
be honest I think now in particular we
can just like walk towards G7 or even
Castle sometimes yeah you need to but
but I like controlling the H7 square
with the Rope because if we Castle we
very often will have to play King G7
Rook h8 very quickly anyway if the
bishop if the bishop drops back and we
start facing windy three threads uh
which is why I like the uh the king f8
G7 maneuver slightly more and then it
doesn't really feel like we're going to
be without plans especially if I have to
exchange minor pieces then I'm not too
happy
um yeah he's played Knight E5
immediately which just does justify
having pushed H5 so the yh1 on H4 wasn't
on pre yeah I guess Bishop d7s may be
slightly harder to achieve now and if
you play King f8 Magnus could consider
chopping on D5 and playing it and going
and going F4 yeah I like this yeah I
think this actually is more flexible
than
other than gustling either side and
demands sort of more of a reply has
after some thought after 95 Bishop G7 uh
he has gone for one of the plans we were
mentioning which would be five in
castles now if if there were four very
much on the cards but even if you play
it slower let's say black castles we go
to K1 which would be six and we play and
I don't know some sort of oppositional
fashion even like rookie three or geffy
one and then we think about where to put
this guy even those aren't that
comfortable for black because it's so
difficult to figure out what you're
doing against the Knight only five yeah
this exact Pawn structure the knights do
quite a good job of fighting against the
Bishops I guess eventually black plays
like for Cafe eight and hopes to play F6
but Knight G6 is always a question
exactly yeah and uh yeah perhaps you
know having gotten the Rook to E3 and
now we can aim for because I I would
very much like to be able to recapture
on F4 specifically with the Knight I
think I like it more than the Rook uh it
generates sort of more control and maybe
even more threats on the king side yeah
The Rook on the floor looks beautiful
but doesn't really do nearly as much
thoughts for quite a while here and made
a movie e605 which you can understand
from a sort of a purely uh conceptual
point of view like maybe it belongs on
this diagonal more than it belongs only
66 was a very passive square but yeah it
very specifically uh runs on the queen
G1 and you might have to put it back
losing some Tempe because both Queen F3
and queen B3 are suddenly quite annoying
threats which weren't in the position a
moment ago I don't know I didn't even
know what he was getting ready for like
F4 block with a G4 or something but
maybe yeah maybe that was the the
intentionally to have this option and to
maybe try to play Queen H4 next move and
not allow any files to be opened on well
and and he has now missed the tactic as
well he played 2K quite quickly which I
think explains the previous move at
least he was trying to do this but the
snow is very strong
and you start losing material because G2
G4 is coming in hot yeah this looks
horrible G4 yeah this looks horrible so
often out of seven you have to play
Queen D7 and you've just you know
misplaced nothing misplaced a very
important Central Pawn for for nothing
yeah things aren't right
and you're not really emotionally
involved enough to correct them so you
become this kind of a automaton yeah
performing actions you still know
reasonably well how to perform and in
the meantime Knight F7 has not been
found wow that's I think it's amazing
this is an amazing reprieve for for
Prague the position remains very
annoying
but but this is an improvement even
though like what you have to play here
is is still very difficult because the
36 again no I think you I think you
might have to take only five oh that's
because like if you play Bishop E6 here
you really should not have been playing
Bishop 5 earlier and uh taking on E5 now
I guess computers will say that purely
because Knight takes F7 is an even
bigger threat than it was yeah so we get
here and and then we play like Rook C8
Queen E6 King G7 and we chill well to a
degree of chill and actually you can
imagine this setup being somewhat useful
for us because maybe let me make some in
different hopes here now but once you
see that white knight getting around to
C5 he plays it
yeah once you see Knight H4 Knight C5
then you maybe
um I was gonna say start to
reject lines like this but and I think
the the point here is that you would
like to play B6 but then suddenly you
realize you you can't actually support
that pawn yeah b89 C6 yeah because you
run into Forks in this one and now both
I guess both Queen B3 and even rugby
three to a degree just to the issue with
Queen B3 is that we might have to trade
Queens like if blacks make if black
makes some kind of a sensible move here
I don't know Rook C8 or whatever in
order to win that pawn you have to trade
queens and then maybe black
activities yeah with the with the bishop
player maybe has some some drawing
chances even though day four yeah like
I'm not a huge fan either way not a
shocker not a shocker we do think it was
logical and again Bishop takes E5 is an
appetizing no yes
yeah but but now yeah we just go like 22
here and we do play for one next move
ended up very often and you know it's
just oof eventually five in one temper
which is seven it's that
allowing upon grab yeah I think so is
there a trick took on B6 which as we
know if Prague finds Bishop takes C5
there potentially throws away maybe most
of his Advantage maybe all right we
thought that I mean the light had to be
slightly careful yeah and
Prague I think will be forced by
circumstances to find it because Ruby
have already played Knight E4 Blitz
doubt by Magnus and if you allow Knight
C5 here if you if you don't do something
sort of right this moment if you allow
white to one more move to play Knight C5
for Rook B3 or really just about
anything you are lost both tactically
and strategically uh which very often
forces you to find those maybe difficult
moves because like what else can you do
which is also completely fine default
would allow Queen before we yeah the
squares I was offering are just much
much worse than before but even here the
position would become uh very difficult
for white to completely control everyone
which by five if I feels if I if I full
hang and the engine wasn't really hating
there but Queen A5 is even cleaner we
want to play G4 next move 95 is this is
a big fan yeah yeah maybe we'll just
play like Bishop six here or something
yeah Quincy one played by the way yeah
it's the most logical yeah we we knew
this was coming you know we were
absolutely certain this was coming
and why ask any questions at all in this
line I don't really see it before we
have to play yeah if three if three is
strictly the only move because otherwise
you'll lose material if you're D7 we
pretty much should be seven absolutely
forces Knight C3 Queen C5 check you have
to go to the H file I guess H1 is
somewhat better than H2 because at least
Queen tx5 isn't checked but now
options at all it just looks completely
fine for black honestly and it all looks
extremely forced yeah and yeah just as I
said it just it's very very linear yeah
just move by move you can rule out
everything else
and and get there doubting himself but
it's not necessarily such a you know you
you shouldn't be reading too much into
it yeah the entire thing is blitzed out
on Knight C3 so far
okay
yeah Queen C5
the only thing oh this is a this is a
study well Prague after Quincy frog yeah
so in this position we go King H2 it you
know D4 rookie for uh this is like a
timer packed yeah and white has nothing
better than than the main line is just
absolutely insane rookie currently
currently reading on my screen is just
absolutely insane either this is Queen
C7 F6 King H7 and this is somehow a draw
ah yes and that's Queen f8 and then you
set the queen yeah and this is a draw
words
what is chess yeah yeah then again I
think he will be he thinks he's three
though is just such a difficult move to
make here yeah Prague either missed
rookie 4 or has calculated this or
neither and then he's in trouble because
he doesn't play Bishop C6 he goes D4
very quickly and now rookie 4 is on the
board and it feels like you no longer
have options you have to go do takes you
have to go see too yeah the King on H2
is also not very safe so it feels like
you have to go for this position and
this position shouldn't really be that
much of a problem honestly with the King
as open as it is one of us will still
play on and if you imagine the skin kind
of catafluencing itself over to A5 even
if you lose something on the king side
it becomes somewhat exciting but I don't
know if you ever get that okay the
sequence 27 on the board and again
Prague could go for Glory here but I
think in particular in the view of what
happened over the past few days
that is has to be exceedingly unlikely
that he goes for Glory here I think less
than uh five percent chance in the whole
place C2 I mean if nothing else was
playable he would simply because nobody
really I mean I feel very self-conscious
saying saying sentences like nobody
wants to resign because obviously some
people very much want to resign in every
single position and even do occasionally
but
but uh yeah practice Place young man wow
I am I am in awe
if he finds his way through the that
kind of maze of complications that's
going to be I am in search of this
I don't understand how how do you how do
you choose this or the other thing
that's off to Prague yeah we know it's a
draw because the engine told us as much
but is it maybe simpler because we can
go before Queen C7 that's Queen C7 not
make a draw yeah just briefly because I
feel like mongers will think for much of
his remaining time here choosing between
a four and E6 he doesn't really have
very many other choices but I think he
probably by this point knows E6 is a
forest draw and not not a very difficult
one either hang on a second uh e 16 C7
G3 C1 Queen E7 now there might be Queens
I have to say one C2 uh ah we need
although this is still uh Quincy yeah
this is weird right because we get this
for it this really strange position
which I think white is running any risks
actually maybe White's just winning
maybe what's winning yeah just straight
up winning that one at least I can play
it but like you said it's probably hard
to avoid yeah
it was very expected I I think you know
in terms of comparing uh this one and uh
and this one
you know the other one is a draw whereas
here perhaps there is no Perpetual
perhaps black does take one of six you
play Community C5 yeah and we play a
queen ending which we assume is a draw
but right luckily again for him he's got
to find these moves strictly of course
yeah so here yeah I don't think there's
a choice I mean queen C4 apparently is
also a draw but yeah nobody does that
which moves with the speed it's gonna be
before move 40 so yeah after 40 maybe
you play Queen C4 but yeah multi-purpose
move unless he yeah okay he does play
Queen C7 I was gonna say I let's see Mrs
Queen D7 or something in that line uh I
thought he was forcing a Perpetual but
he's found it yeah and played Magnus
also has absolutely no choice if you
don't play F6 queen of Fate you lose the
simplest way for black to create the
thread here is just like Quincy one
takes H5 check and then we need to we
can play Queen G6 and just cover G7 uh
so yeah you we don't really have any
leeway to to pass here with white
unsurprisingly I should will be played
benefit will be played this will be more
40. Prague will have a choice of either
resigning or playing Queen to xc5 so
um
all of this will appear on the board and
the other question for Magnus will be
sort of where to put the king I'm pretty
sure it's D3 Prague will now think
as expected we we knew this mission was
appearing on the board yeah before it
has
these guys are beasts just so accurate
uh both Magnus Amtrak I mean first of
all Prague chose here to go see two and
notebook take C5
which in itself is quite a remarkable
decision of having five minutes on the
clock and then both of them very very
cleanly found the absolute best line of
of the position which starts with B4 and
then Magnus just allows
and black to get a second Queen to
create matching threads and in this
position The Only Way Forward is to give
one of your Queens away and then pick up
the Rook only five as check manglers
didn't play A4 which I thought was kind
of a logical move to immediately started
doing something it's like you play Queen
E8 here I guess taking some squares
under control and also indirectly
protecting the pawn actually that's not
true that's not what the point is right
we're also keeping in touch with the GC
with the F7 on Brad played queen of fan
check the king went forward King G7
check G8 check engine seven interesting
that Magnus actually chooses to make a
quiet move with the King on G7 and not
on G8 this one could go for a long time
Queen endings black could be determining
for a while with lots of tracks later
Queen E5 but if I shed blade uh and uh
King G8 really the the only move that
makes any sense even optically like
everything else allows white additional
options which you absolutely don't want
to do well kinda started the race and
he's gonna play B5 at the right time
yeah you can you can play like Queen G1
here King the six you can just take on
G2 why those B5 a b A6
yeah
yeah uh 24 chosen by Magnus I assume we
take I assume we we want our passers to
be passers right we just go yeah we do a
bit of counting and then white creating
that passport anyways we might as well
create some counter play yeah like oh no
wait no no I think I play 28. it looks
uh yeah I play Queen A8 and then you you
have to choose whether I take the cheap
one or you yeah you can trade g4a but
then on the board as open as this we
should not be losing or you can play
King B6 G2 and once again like this is a
bit too far progressed for for white to
have we'll we'll watch because I think
this one is uh more clear-cut and yeah
Prague does I think very correctly you
you do want activity more than you want
like some kind of an uh innate belief
that you will give a Perpetual to this
King even though you probably will but
like you'd much rather have a policy too
here that will feel a lot better if you
have a Pawn on G2 here so he plays G4
Magnum star has to choose between ba and
B6 I don't know what the difference
necessarily is I guess both of them
should be B6 feels inherently a bit more
risky
so
I'm not sure so you do something like
this and you pretend I don't know how
you pretend though like what if I play
Queen F2 here ah Queen G4 ah and then B7
maybe and with queen of two is probably
yeah
yeah I'm worried about B7 right because
g2b8 there's a weight on G8 I can't
really do that
um yeah
the engine tries like getting the king
over to H2 but I'm pretty sure we will
be able to find some activity for it
that's really clever though I've got to
say yeah like it goes It goes like this
yeah it goes King 16 E5 but now we play
Queen C6 quite happily and start giving
checks of our own it's it's a draw like
we we know it's a draw
yeah I think I think the the human way
to play this for a win if if there is a
way to play this for a win I think uh
you just go Queen G4 Queen G3
uh you play like King B5 in this
position and you hope somehow that your
opponent doesn't give you a Perpetual
immediately yeah like the queen has to
stay in touch with the G1 Square black
has
a queen only a protected like maybe King
C7 but Queen d8 is not really a threat I
just go H5 H4 and so on why why am I
supposed to be worse at all here as
black this is one I mean this is not
fully without risk for white either like
if you miscalculate and get the Queens
off then I mean black promise the G Pawn
the H pawns running yeah I guess you
play some of the queen B6 but there's no
way you can actually Force the king back
to the eighth right I just stay on G7 H7
squares there's no way you can create a
thrift that I don't have an answer for
Magnus playing on
um now there's there's a very wide
Choice like you can even ignore king of
G3 it's still a drop somehow if
it gets to H2 then you start to worry as
black yeah because then Queen B6 Queen
B8 is I mean yeah what do you I I guess
you just uh you play either 26 or you
know three or something
and uh kind of force
the issue of trading this for this point
in particular I think it's just a just a
very solid choice just asking asking
popping the question how does white
actually arrange that uh a for G now uh
that exchange oh you can go Queen G8 A8
I think uh-huh yeah just very simply
because I don't think we can just direct
like the threads along the back rank are
a little bit too strong for us to pull
around but we take and we go jiban and I
guess Magnus goes for something like
this actually yeah we you you choose a
good Square in the center somewhere at
least 24 check and then yeah maybe Queen
uh
it's difficult because like if you play
A6 it feels like you just lose it to
checks yeah maybe Queen D5 the previous
message yeah my Hope was King G7 and we
go Queen D4 and then we get to play a
discovery check yeah kind of three
played in the meantime and yeah can
continue
doing nothing like black also has no
threats but yeah I'm being H7 because
you still have to play eight if you want
to play on and now in this position you
you don't start with the check at all
yeah like you you don't actually have a
check do you lose a temper yeah I mean
the A6 is still obviously just a draw
because black you know with the white
Pawn already on A6 why trans precisely
zero risks but yeah he just was sort of
unimpressed with what Prague was doing
and kind of mentally checked out from
looking for the best move
because I think he missed Knight F7 with
at such speed as well like he did it
instantly and broke a few minutes
happened yeah Rook everyone happened
pretty much in a blink of an eye
normally normally he doesn't miss
tactics like this and uh yeah yeah it's
just gone because after 27 I thought
maybe the only chance is going to be
seven but in this position we can even
take with the pawn because in 1994 is
it's very very painful and then he just
calculated cleanly and precisely and
played quickly and uh just just a very
very impressive feat of defensive
resourcefulness yeah man it hasn't put a
single foot wrong
ng8 on the board he's choosing between
G7 and H7 there's no
difference yeah G7 looks but yeah no
difference uh in terms of uh objective
evaluation but yeah I think you pretty
much always choose G7 there's no reason
to choose anything else j7 also really
makes sure that he plays A8 because you
you can't really play 24 and lose the
queen like you you no longer have a
choice which is very useful in practice
position just making sure that you don't
have to calculate any extra stuff was he
offer it to draw
yeah it did look like Magnus is looking
over at the score sheet he was looking
over at something being H7 chosen still
a draw of course yeah okay
um also weirdly the engine goes between
C3 check here and the responsibility
check in this position is for some
reason Queen D4
ah whoa oh because you pull out we're
gonna play G1 you cover all the checks
You've Won I'm thinking of four
oh my God I think we're gonna see this I
love this I love this so much come on
PC3 check come on from his Queen E4 is
still probably just a drop yeah no this
is still a draw of course but I've won
Queen C3 check on the board now I want
Magnus to be like shaken a bit when he
realizes G1 is coming and he has no
checks it's going to play Queen C3 for
sure whoa whoa there we go Peter it's on
the board
this is this is so great and look at
Magnus he's panicking he's like
calculating before he's written his move
down look he's smoking as well he's
enjoying this mindless is enough of an
artist to actually enjoy the fact that
G1 is playable next move
showing this yeah might as well just
play Queen before it's still it's still
in that draw like the the H Pawn is way
too far the a pawn is too close you
still give a Perpetual here nothing
changed in reality nothing really
changed but
yeah 24 or maybe Candice yeah people are
asking people asking you if Queen G4 can
be met by uh F6 check but then you've
disc like you can but I don't think it
changes then ah okay you want to
remember this is the same like I can go
into King D5 and then it's gonna have
three I can play 24 chairs and I even
meet uh Queen D4 just for artistic value
with G1
[Laughter]
yeah I know but oh wait now we have lost
okay kimchi hates her
yeah Community four player your Magnus
doesn't really want to like he's he's
done now he
uh
he knows he shouldn't really fool around
too much yeah I think we're racing
towards the handshake now yeah
yeah Prague also knows this is known
very very obvious draw so yeah I don't
think Prague will now pretend for too
long
which is looking C4 a607 here it's too
close
yeah yeah way too close and uh I think
cash against Iranian also is going to be
a draw but let's stick with this one uh
for now until
what I'm assuming is going to be
handshake
yep just all the tracks
um
nothing that's the game yeah it
definitely featured some mistakes in the
early running Prague or maybe did not
react to uh the opening novelty in the
best be in the best fashion found
himself in a bit of a rut and honestly
I I want to kind of retract those
statements because in this entire game
the only two moves I want to criticize
Irish by 500k8 yeah because we know that
black for some reason is not even worse
after Rook C8 here because princess I
told us so
and then after Bishop F5 21 already the
position is difficult you maybe just
have to admit you were wrong and put it
back and rookie 8 was pretty much losing
to Knight F7 we we do know that is true
yeah but uh his reaction to this before
was maybe not the most ambitious but it
was definitely sensible
and if this position is not worse
why should we be too sharply critical of
what he's done in the run-up to it and
once again once once this position
appeared on the board
I think
it was just perfect he played it
absolutely perfectly